I have this sense
that there's just going to be a new
startup
that's going to basically be the page
rank inventor which has become the new
Tech Giant
I don't know I would love to hear your
kind of opinion if Google meta
and Microsoft there as gigantic
companies able to Pivot so hard to
create new products like some of it is
just even hiring people or having uh
corporate structure that allows for the
crazy young kids to come in and just
create something totally new
do you think it's possible or do you
think it'll come from a startup yeah it
is there's always big question which is
you get this feeling I hear about this a
lot from CEOs founder CEOs where it's
like wow we have 50 000 people it's now
harder to do new things than it was when
we had 50 people yeah like what has
happened so that's a recurring
phenomenon um by the way that's one of
the reasons why there's always startups
and why there's Venture Capital um it's
just that's that's like a Timeless uh
kind of thing so that that's one
observation um on a page rank um we can
talk about that but on pagerank
specifically on page rank um there
actually is a page so there is a page
rank already in the field and it's the
Transformer right so the the big
breakthrough was the Transformer um and
uh the Transformer was invented in on uh
2017. at Google and this is actually
like really an interesting question
because it's like okay the Transformers
like why does open AI even exist like
the Transformers invested at Google why
didn't Google I asked a guy I asked a
guy I know who was senior at Google
brain kind of when this was happening
and I said if Google had just gone flat
out to the wall and just said look we're
going to launch we're going to launch
equivalent of gpt4 as fast as we can um
he said I said when could we have had it
and he said 2019. yeah they could have
just done a two-year Sprint with the
Transformer and and benefit because they
already had the compute at scale they
already had all the training data they
could have just done it there's a
variety of reasons they didn't do it
this is like a classic big company thing
um IBM invented the relational database
in 19 in the 1970s let it sit on the
Shelf as a paper Larry Ellison picked it
up and built Oracle Xerox Park invented
the interactive computer they let it sit
on the Shelf Steve jobs came and turned
into the Macintosh right and so there is
this pattern now having said that
sitting here today like Google's in the
game right so Google you know maybe
maybe they maybe they let like a
four-year Gap there go there that they
maybe shouldn't have but like they're in
the game and so now they've got you know
now they're committed they've done this
merger they're bringing in demos they've
got this merger with deep mind yeah you
know they're piling in resources there
are rumors that they're you know
building up an incredible you know super
llm um you know Way Beyond what we even
have today
um and they've got you know unlimited
resources and a huge you know they've
been challenged their honor yeah I had a
chance to hang out with someone a couple
days ago and we took this walk and
there's this giant new building
uh well there's going to be a lot of AI
work uh being done and it's kind of
this ominous feeling of
like the fight is on yeah
like there's this beautiful Silicon
Valley nature like birds of chirping and
this giant building and it's like uh the
Beast has been awakened yeah and there's
and then like all the big companies are
waking up to this they have the compute
but also the little guys have uh it
feels like they have all the tools to
create the killer product that uh and
then there's all the tools to scale if
you have a good idea if you have the
page rank idea so I there's several
things that it's page right there's page
rank the algorithm and the idea and
there's like the implementation of it
and I think like killer product is not
just the idea like the transformer it's
the implementation something something
really compelling about it like you just
can't look away something like
um the algorithm behind Tick Tock versus
Tick Tock itself like the actual
experience of tick tock that just you
can't look away it feels like somebody's
gonna come up with that and it could be
Google but it feels like it's just
easier and faster to do for a startup
yeah so so the startup the huge the huge
Advantage the startups have is they just
there's no sacred cows there's no
historical Legacy to protect there's no
need to reconcile your new plan with the
existing strategy there's no
communication overhead there's no you
know big companies or big companies
they've got pre-meetings planning for
the meeting then they then they have the
post meeting the recap then they have
the presentation the board then they
have the next round of meetings yeah and
that's that's the meetings that's the
elapsed time when the startup launches
its product right so so so so there's a
Timeless right yeah so there's a
Timeless thing there now yeah what the
startups don't have is everything else
right so startups they have a brand they
don't have customer relationships
they've gotten a distribution they've
got no you know scale I mean sitting
here today they can't even get gpus
right like there's like a GPU shortage
startups are literally stalled out right
now because they can't get chips which
is like super weird yeah um they got the
cloud yeah but the clouds run out of
chips
um right and then and then and then to
the extent the clouds have chips they
allocate them to the big customers not
small customers right and so so so so so
the small companies lack everything
other than the ability to just do
something new yeah right um and this is
the Timeless race in battle and this is
kind of the point I tried to make in the
essay which is like both sides of this
are good like it's really good to have
like highly scaled tech companies that
can do things that are like at
staggering levels of sophistication it's
really good to have startups that can
launch brand new ideas they ought to be
able to both do that and compete they
neither one ought to be subsidized or
protected from the others like that's
that's to me that's just like very
clearly the idealized world it is the
world we've been in for AI up until now
and then of course there are people
trying to shut that down but my hope is
that you know the best outcome clearly
will be if that continues